It's super clever. I mean, the argument is completely circular, right?
They just say you're a racist and you say, well,
but you have no evidence of my racism. They say, well,
you don't even recognize your own racism. You say, well then how am I racist?
They say, because you're complicit in a system of racism you say, right.
But the system isn't isn't racist.
Like you can't point to something in the streets, you know,
but it results in racial inequality. And therefore it is a racist system.
And therefore you are complicit in the system and therefore you're a racist and
you say, okay, well,
but all systems perpetuate racial inequality by even saying that you're
demonstrating your white fragility, which means you're a racist, right?
Like this is basic Salem witch trial. If you sink, then you are innocence.
And if you float in your way.
[Inaudible].
Sorta talked about this a little bit before,
but do you think there is a fundamental reason for that,
that there is a fundamental reason that underlies the philosophy of someone who
broadly is on the left versus on the right,
that why people on the right are willing to do it.
If I put someone on the left on my show, I put Marianne Williamson on,
I put on Andrew Yang, Tulsi, average,
all the people on the right virtually who disagree with them say, ah, you know,
I disagree with her and him on this and that and the other thing, but it's glad.
Yeah. I'm glad you had the conversation. If I put someone,
if I put you on or pre-ground the lefties go bananas,
I'm endorsing white supremacy. And the.
Because I think that for the left and there are many liberals who buy into this,
all, all human relations are power relations. Right?
You saw this in sort of as reclined response to Matt Iglesias, right?
How did I end up on the same side as Matt Yglesias, man,
I've got the Ralph wiggle of the internet, right? Like how,
how has this happened? But Matt Yglesias had the temerity to sign that letter.
And then as recline was like,
there are a lot of people who stand up for them for free speech who are really
doing this because it's a way of gaining power. And for a lot of people,
this is on the left is how they think of things, right?
All human relationships are power dynamics.
There are no big principles that we all share. Like freedom of speech matters.
That's just a bunch of people who are seeking to use the principle of freedom of
speech as a weapon in order to reenact the hierarchy in order to preserve the
hierarchy. And this argument,
you see being made more and more by folks on the left,
which is that rights are not actually universal principles that we all should
hold to rights are just a way for me to shut you up while I'm still speaking.
Right. And that's,
and I think that the liberal left has been somewhat warm to that
argument for, for awhile, at least warm enough that they're willing to hear it.
And they just didn't see it turning on them at any point.
The left moved so far so fast that the liberals were like,
we were with you up until the point where you started canceling us.
And then we realized, Oh wait, that was, uh, that was a bad mistake. Right?
Iglesias was one of the guys who was like cheering on there's no cancel culture
or cancel the cancellation doesn't exist. And then the,
and then it came for him and he was like, ah, this is bad. Right guys.
It's like, yes, it's bad. Well, yes, thank you for recognizing it as bad.
Do you love seeing that now where there's this move by them now,
AOC is doing this and a bunch of other people to completely tell us the cancel
culture doesn't even exist.
It's an exact statement of your imagination. But when she's not explaining that,
that people are shooting each other in the inner city for bread, for bread,
right. Which is that,
that's why you should want her on their playground is because they're hungry.
That's what I do when I'm hungry. You know, I say to my wife,
are we out of cereal? She says, yes. And I go and shoot somebody in the face.
That's that's, that's the way I deal with my own personal hanger. But it,
but when she's not saying that sort of stuff,
this is becoming a very popular notion on the left,
which is that all America is a group of people who are dispossessed and the
people who are victimizers and any principle that exists in the system that is
the victimizing system. Again,
this goes back to the Kennedy point or the Robin D'Angelo point.
Any aspect of that system is inherently bad and reinforces a power hierarchy.
And so you must remove those systems of power in order to allow the
dispossessed, to claim their full share of the earth.
You're a scifi guy. Do you sort of admire the beauty of their evil?
You know what I mean? Like really at some level,
like to create a system that that proves itself in and of itself is
the proof. Like there's a certain beauty to that as evil as it is.
The argument is completely circular, right? They, they just say,
you're a racist and you say, well, but you have no evidence of my races.
And they say, well, you don't even recognize your own racism. You say,
well then how am I racist? They said,
because you're complicit in a system of racism say, right,
but the system isn't isn't racist,
like you can't point to something that straits you. No,
but it results in racial inequality. And therefore it is a racist system.
And therefore you are complicit in the system and therefore you're a racist and
you say, okay, well,
but all systems perpetuate racial inequality that even saying that you're
demonstrating your white fragility, which means you're a racist, right?
Like this is basic Salem witch trial.
If you sink then your innocence and if you float then your wedge.
Yeah. All right. So a lot of this actually is very much the point of the book.
So just quickly before we fully go into that, uh,
just let's just do COVID quickly.
Like where the hell are we at in this let's let's just talk about California for
a second. But we just,
in the last couple of days went into another freaking lockdown.
It's beautiful outside. I, I'm not sure what the beach situation is,
whether we can go there, but I know I can't go to a restaurant. I was like,
what the hell is going on here at this point?
What do you think is honestly happening at this time?
I think it was honestly happening is that you have a deadly disease that has
probably somewhere between a two times and six times deadly as an
effect, uh, as the fluids, if you can point to 1.6, uh, infection,
fatality rate, uh, and that's dangerous. And it's very, very infectious.
And all of that is true.
The whole point of flattening the curve was to prevent the overwhelming of the
healthcare system.
We are not seeing the healthcare system being overwhelmed right now.
And so the idea that the only tactic that is available is full-scale lockdown I
think is, is not backed by evidence.
I am also growing extraordinarily tired of people,
shouting that they are on the side of science while variously changing their
opinion, literally every 15 seconds. So when masks are bad, now masks are good.
Protests are bad with anti-lock and protests. Now protests are good.
And this woke virus, spirits. You so long as you're kneeling for George Floyd,
right? It's crazy. It's utterly nuts. I mean, that, that was,
that was mindbogglingly incredible.
This week said that in effect,
you are allowed to protest because racism is so systemic and profoundly evil
that somehow it supersedes the deadly virus, but everyone else,
a couple of Orthodox Jews playing in a park in Brooklyn.
It's a, it's a seriously woke virus. I mean,
good for Colin Kaepernick who should win the Nobel peace prize as well as the
Nobel prize in biology, because kneeling,
it turns out actually carries coronavirus,
which is pretty awesome when you think about it, but it's yeah,
I think that there've been a bunch of false binaries that have been set up and
those false binaries are things like it's either total lockdown or total
openness.
It annoys me when people on the right treat mask scoring as though it's like a
virtue signal.
And it annoys me on the left when people treat mask wearing as though it's an
incredible virtue signal, you're an evil, evil person.
If you're not wearing a mask,
when you go to sleep at night and you're a better person,
if you wear a mask and on the, and on the right,
there are people for sure who are like, well,
I'm not wearing a mask under any circumstance to violation of my freedoms and
all those kinds of like, just when you're in a popular,
when you're in a populated area with a lot of other people wear a mask,
it isn't that bad.
Like you should do it because you don't want other people to get sick.
It's like, that's the best we can do at this point in time with that said,
the idea that we're going to full scale locked down the entire American economy,
or that we are going to leave children out of school for the next year,
because of COVID like, that seems patently insane to me. I mean,
the reason it seems patently insane is because the data are pretty murky and a
lot of issues. There are absolutely not murky on the risk of children.
There's so little risk to children. If you're under the age of 20,
you have a better chance of dying from the flu than you do with COVID. I mean,
that's just straight stat.
And what that means is that maybe we can come up with some creative solutions
where parents actually have a place where their kids can go for schooling. So,
um, my friend, John Podhoretz over commentary magazine,
I thought he had a good idea. He said, why don't you keep the schools open?
And then you have a bunch of 20 year old proctors,
and then you have the teachers zoomin, why is it the teacher has the zooms,
all the kids at home, right? Why don't they, why don't you just do it at school?
Right. That seems like a fairly decent idea. Um, but the, the,
the incentive structure is created for politicians to lock down because more
sternly, you treat the virus, the better the media are going to treat you,
right? The more virtuous you are. Right? Exactly.
And this is how you see Andrew Cuomo,
who was a garbage heap of a governor in this whole time.
And who now creates magical posters,
tributes to himself with literally a curve that represents the number of dead
bodies in his state, by being treated as though he was great at this,
when his death rate is like eight or nine times, that of Florida,
where Rhonda Santas is the font of all evil and Greg Abbott in Texas,
it's like 11 or 12 times the death rate in Texas like this,
none of the media coverage makes sense. And the media,
there are a bunch of issues here. The politics of it makes more sense.
The media coverage of it makes some sense,
but it's a really ugly sense because the politics have overwhelmed the data.
And then on a data level, there's just a lot. We,
we actually don't know at this point, right?
We don't know whether there's such a thing as T-cell immunity.
That's been one of the theories that herd immunity actually may start to kick in
as low as 20%. This is a theater from Sweden. It could be at 60%.
We don't know whether this thing is how far away you have to be from somebody,
or they say six feet, but who was hanging a meter until five minutes ago,
by the way.
Technically, my guys measured were seven feet. Oh.
Yeah, no. And I insisted on that, like,
I'm a person who is taking this very seriously, right? I mean,
like I I've been taking it seriously cause I have 65 year old parents.
So I'm not on the, let's be skeptical of all of this stuff.
But the idea that like,
it's going to wipe out vast swabs of the American public and that,
and that it's the most dangerous thing that,
that has ever existed on planet earth.
And that we have to shut down the economy ad infinitum. Here's the problem.
Has anyone ever actually done on the, on the lockdown side,
any analysis of what the costs are on the other side,
all I hear is if you mentioned those costs,
then you're bad and you don't go back into the things and that's, that's insane.
Like these are public policy decisions and we should obviously be having
conversations about how to protect the most vulnerable and also how to trans
people back in to work. I mean,
I've been saying for a long time that it may end up being that the way that we
end up moving forward is what one,
I think it was Hebrew university or Tel Aviv.
University scientists suggested was controlled avalanche.
The idea was if you're most vulnerable, you stay home.
And we figured out ways to protect you. And if you're less vulnerable,
then you go out and if you get it, you get it.
And then you're one person closer to herd immunity that that may be effectively
defacto what we're seeing anyway. Right?
Cause this is how let's be real about this. If you're 20, this is.
And this is where they're going to say, you want to kill people.
That's what last time you were here, you were here for my book launch.
And I remember you were the number one trend on Twitter because you said we're
going to have to deal with some level of death. It's a problem we don't want to,
but that's just the reality. And then they came after you and said, no, no,
no one should die in our perfect.
And I made the, I made the very pure and obvious which everyone,
everyone understands. The argument I was making,
which is that if you are looking at days of life versus just lives lost,
that is a different calculation. And it has done by actuaries every single day.
The federal government has actuaries that do this on every single policy.
But again, the, the media narrative is, is very easy here.
If you don't mirror the policies they want, then you're a,
you're a grandma Keller who wants to murder your, your own grandma.
It doesn't matter that I'm taking all sorts of extraordinary measures and our
protect my own parents on this thing.
If you're looking for more honest and thoughtful conversations about politics,
instead of nonstop yelling, check out our politics playlist.
And if you want to watch full interviews on a variety of topics,
watch our full episode playlists, all right, over here,
and to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and click the notification bell.